uk consumers enjoy the luxury of cheap
plentiful food and a varied and
unseasonal diet but that
relies on imports of fresh and processed
produce 40
of which comes from the european union
what and how much we import changes with
the seasons but in winter
90 of lettuces 85 percent of tomatoes
and 70 of soft fruit comes from the eu
now if there's no deal
importers would have to pay tariffs
that's taxes on
imported goods how much depends on what
it is
and while the average tariff would be
over 20 it'll be higher
for some products take branded cheese
like feta halloumi or gorgonzola they'd
have a 55
tariff cured pork like italian
prosciutto or bavarian sausages
would have 31 and a drizzle of olive oil
will be 32 more expensive to import
in the event of a no deal what does that
add up to for the consumer
that's hard to say precisely but there
are some
estimates the british retail consortium
says tariffs across the board
will add 3.1 billion pounds to our
collective shopping bill the food and
drink federation
says it will be more like 10 billion
pounds or 360 pounds per household
once tariffs on packaging and other
elements of production
are added supermarkets will play a key
role in deciding how much cost to absorb
to stay competitive and our food choices
may be affected by price
which could favor uk produce but even
with a deal
and no tariffs new red tape and border
delays
will add costs the lse estimates new
procedures could
increase the cost of goods by eight
percent with import declarations
alone adding four billion pounds to
traders costs
every year now it's worth saying the uk
currently has the cheapest food
in western europe it's eight percent
cheaper than average you can see on this
index how it is
much better placed than some heavily
taxed countries not
in the eu but deal or no deal the cost
of food
is going to rise for businesses and very
possibly consumers
while choice and availability may be
reduced
at least at first and none of that was
on the menu
offered to voters in 2016